SPEAKER 1: Can you please
give a warm welcome
to today's speaker, Ian McClean.
[APPLAUSE]
IAN MCCLEAN: Good afternoon.
I'm on.
So welcome unofficially to
the start of the long weekend.
And it's interesting,
because when Caroline invited
me to speak here,
I didn't realize
until I looked in the
calendar to realize
that I got the afternoon just
after lunch slot on the Friday
before the start of the
long bank holiday weekend.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
IAN MCCLEAN: So the one
thing that I almost did
was I thought long and
hard about packing a mirror
so that I wouldn't be the
only person in the room
and there would at least be one
other person in the audience.
So I can only
conclude on that basis
that you guys are the
optimistic learners.
So I better be clear that
I don't disappoint you,
either with your optimism
or with your learning.
And this is my first
talk at Google.
So I fit into that
category, Caroline.
And it's really good to
be here, and particularly
on the run in to
the long weekend.
And we're going to spend a
little bit less than an hour.
And I'm going to make
it a little interactive.
So there's going to be
some of me, some of you,
and then we'll kind of make
up the rest of it in between.
But I think everybody starts
off by telling their story.
I'm going to give you a
very, very short version
of the story.
So I'm the founder
of a business,
which is called Flow Group.
And I started the
business 20 years ago.
So it's actually 20
years old this year.
And I didn't have any great
grand ambitions or plans
to be an empire builder.
And we built the business pretty
slowly, steadily, organically.
And we now have a business
that has got operations
across four continents.
And during the last
20 years or so,
we've worked with a very, very
wide range of organizations.
In fact, these are just
some of that brands
that you'll be familiar with.
In the last 10
years alone, we've
worked with over 300
different, mostly,
international organizations in
all sorts of shapes and sizes.
So many of them are
bluechip multinationals.
And a number of them
are sports governing
bodies, government agencies,
voluntary organizations, NGOs.
We are kind of
industry agnostic.
I think we worked with
38 different industries
in the last 10 years alone.
And the one thing that
we bring to the party
is the common element of people.
And that's probably the one
single variable or expertise
that we specialize in.
Now, when you looked
at the list of things.
We call the things
down at the bottom
the centers of excellence.
You'll probably be very
familiar with them.
And you can imagine that that's
what an organization that
would do what we
do around people
would cluster their activities
in under the headings
that you see.
The one that put the
red circle around
is the one which is
probably least familiar,
if at all familiar to you,
which is called GreenLine.
And that's what I'm going
to talk to you about or work
with you on this afternoon is
this GreenLine proposition.
And the reason that I chose
this is because Caroline kind of
invited us to think about
something that would
add value or be interesting.
Because it didn't
exist five years ago.
And five years ago,
we saw something
that was missing in the
market in the organizations
that we were working
with across the globe.
And we created-- myself and
my co-founder of GreenLine
who is based in Toronto,
Blair Steinbach.
And his background
is neuroscience.
So he, for almost a
quarter of a century,
has worked with all
sorts of agencies
from athletes to
government agencies
to military to
business organizations
in the area of how do you
perform best under pressure.
And that combined with our own
experience and field research
came to create something
which we call GreenLine.
And here's the proposition.
So the title that
I've chosen for today
is this whole idea of what
I've put up on the screen here.
So it's a proposition.
And there are three key
words to share with you
or to think about for the
purposes of the next hour.
The first is effective leaders.
I'm guessing that all of us
here at this stage in our career
have had the experience of what
it's like to work under or work
with an effective leader.
We probably have
even more experience
of what it's like
to work with or work
under an ineffective leader.
And they are different.
And the difference between
effective leadership
and ineffective leadership
is that the effective leader,
he or she, has thinking
and behaviors that
cause them to be able to
create an environment, which
in this world we call
culture, which is productive
and engaging and
gets great work done.
And we all probably
have the experience
of both during our
careers at this point.
So this whole idea of effective.
The second word,
which is interesting,
is the OS, or the
Operating System.
Because effective leaders with
their thinking and behavior
probably don't even
know what they're doing
or how they're doing it, right?
They just show up
the way they show up
with the thinking and behavior.
And it's underneath the surface.
So the idea of an
operating system
is a very good analogy
for this proposition.
And actually, it was
brought to our attention
working with one of the big four
accountancy firms in London.
And they were wowed by
the GreenLine proposition,
which we're about to explore.
And they ran into a challenge.
Because they said,
well, hang on a second.
Where do we deploy this?
Because we can see this
is so good as a basic--
and they called it
our operating system.
It's going to affect our teams
and make our teams better
and more collaborative.
It's going to affect the way we
interact with our key clients
on our customer relations.
It's going to help
with our innovation,
because we need to be innovative
and creative in a changing
environment.
And it's going to help
with our efficiency
and our effectiveness
by reducing down
waste and increasing
speed of execution.
But it's all under the surface.
And we know that the value
of the operating system
is that, if you've got a
robust operating system, then
you can run more
programs simultaneously.
You've got higher efficiency and
higher speed with your process.
And you get less blue screens
of death, which in leadership
terms is pretty invaluable.
So what we did was, over
the last four or five years,
we've managed to
codify and build
the evidence for what is
the operating system that
differentiates effective leaders
from ineffective leaders.
And that's what
GreenLine has become.
And one of the other
interesting elements of it
is, in spite of
the fact that we've
got a pretty mature business
after 15 years and 5 years ago,
in the last five years,
the GreenLine proposition
amongst our clients
now accounts for 40%
of our revenue from a
standing start, from nil.
I'm looking out at
the audience here.
And I'm imagining
there aren't many of us
that remember there was a
motor oil advert in the 1970s.
And the tag line for it was,
it gets to parts of the engine
that other oils don't reach.
Well, we found that
GreenLine seems
to get to parts of organizations
and people's psyche
that other types of
development doesn't reach.
So we call it the
Castrol GTX of develop.
That's what we are.
So for today, I'm going to
share with you a few things.
The first thing is
I'm going to give you
a context where this came
from apart from the history.
So where does it apply?
How does it work?
The second thing
we're going to do
is I'm going to share with
you a very simple model.
And the model is very simple.
The third thing we're going
to do is the methodology
of the operating system is
broken down into, as you'll see
here, seven do's
and seven don'ts.
And we've got cards.
We've got seven red cards.
In the current
footballing environment,
that's pretty understandable
and intelligible what that does.
And then we got
seven green cards,
which are the very
opposite of the red cards.
So I'm going to
share those with you.
And then that's
effectively what we're
going to spend our
time at this afternoon.
There's going to be some
audience participation
as we go along.
I'll engage with you at
the appropriate moment
and get some input.
Because I'll be very
interested in your
take on some of this stuff.
So let's just talk about
context for a second.
When we talk about context
when we look at business,
we look at it as a
game of two halves
just extending on the
football analogy for a second.
On one half or on
one side of business,
you've got what we
call the mechanics.
And the mechanics are simply
the structures and systems
and processes and
policies, procedures--
they will begin with P--
the strategies that
are necessary to create
order in what otherwise
would be chaos.
So they are very necessary.
And they create order, and
they create transparency.
So this is the
mechanics of business.
On the other side,
you've got the humanics.
Because I've still yet to
see a project deliver itself.
I've still yet to see a
strategy implement itself.
And the interesting
thing about business
and our experience over the
last quarter of a century or so
is that, when there is a problem
and something needs fixing
and the business has to go
to try to find a solution,
where do you think
it typically goes?
Do you think it goes to
fix it to the humanics
or to the mechanics?
What's your sense?
Almost exclusively,
it's the mechanics.
Let's write a new policy.
Let's restructure.
Let's take it with the system
or investigate the system.
We had a classic
example of this with one
of the leading banks that
moved to an outsource model
just over 10 years ago.
One of the things that
came into our orbit
was the performance
management area.
And they knew they needed
to do something with it.
So they'd outsource it, and
they centralized everything.
They realized, when they
did their due diligence,
that there were 65 different
performance management
systems out there in the group.
And that wouldn't do.
So what they decided they
needed to do what they needed
to find one that
was going to be fit
for purpose and
the silver bullet
for all performance management.
So they went out, and they
spent two years investigating,
crafting, recrafting.
And two years later, they
came up with the silver bullet
performance management system.
They ran it for six months.
After six months,
they abandoned it.
The reason they abandoned it is
because they realized when they
did their
investigation as to why
it wasn't working that
the problem or the cause
was not with the system.
It was basically
that people didn't
have the skill or the
confidence to have
the type of conversations
you need to have in order
to keep performance going.
So it's a classic example
of an organization
looking in the wrong place
to try to solve the problem
and prioritizing
mechanics over humanics.
And actually, it's
very understanding.
Because mechanics
are predictable.
They're tangible.
They're measurable.
People, on the other
hand, they're messy.
A manager in the very early
stages of my own career
took me aside and
said, Ian, you're
going to learn one thing
about organizations.
All problems come
with hair on top.
Or not, as the case may be.
And it's actually true.
And if you think about it, the
only way to get anything done
is through human interaction,
whatever that is.
And we've kind of tagged
the idea of conversations
onto GreenLine.
Because the lowest common
denominator or base
unit of currency
of all interaction
is the individual conversation.
And if you think about
individual conversations,
when I talk about conversations
in the current epoch,
it's not just face to
face anymore, obviously.
It's not just the telephone
anymore, obviously.
It's not just meetings
anymore, which
are now virtual and global.
But it's also inclusive of
and trumped by-- if you pardon
the expression--
the electronic conversation.
So you put all of those
channels together,
and I got a question for you.
How many interactions
do you think
happened through those
channels on a daily basis?
I'm not even going
to talk about Google.
I'm just even talking
about Ireland.
I'm not even talking
I'm talking about your own team.
We had one client mad enough
to undertake a challenge
to investigate and
come up with a number.
And I'll tell you
who the client was.
The client was a retailer in
Ireland, Primark, or Penneys
to you and I. And
they discovered
that there were 220,000
interactions that take place
across their network
on a daily basis.
Now, the question I have, and
it's a rhetorical question,
is, do you think that the
quality of the conversations
or interactions
that are happening
are having an effect or
an impact on the business?
OK, you don't even need
to answer that one.
That's not even the audience
participation point.
What we've discovered is
that there are basically
three outcomes to
any interaction.
And it's a little bit
like, if it's a machine,
then you need to drive it.
And if you need a drive it,
you probably got a gear shift.
And those of us who've
got automatic cars--
and anybody from the US wouldn't
know what anything else is,
I'm sure--
you've got three settings
on your gearstick.
So the first is D. You
have the interaction.
You have the engagement.
You have a conversation.
Business moves on.
There's a second
category of interaction--
N, neutral.
Conversation happens,
and nothing happens.
But there's a third
category of interaction.
And the third category
of interaction
is R, which stands for--
AUDIENCE: Reverse.
IAN MCCLEAN: Reverse.
In GreenLine language,
we call it residue.
Because what ends up
happening is, now,
as a result of this
conversation, poorly handled,
poorly communicated
or executed, now, it's
not just one
conversation we've had.
Now, there's a multitude of
conversations that escalate
or ripple out from this.
Now, instead of
having one meeting,
we need to have a series
of meetings, many of them
unofficial and in car parks
and in coffee coolers.
Now, instead of having
a few people involved,
it's escalated.
Emails have gone out.
CC, BCC-- now, the head of
the department is involved.
Oh, and by the way,
if this is at home,
it's your mother-in-law.
We call this residue.
And residue actually has a cost.
The way it shows up--
and this has me kind of
short-circuiting this--
from our analysis of
it or our research is
it shows up in two camps.
One impact of residue is it
creates a lack of clarity
or/and it creates a
second category, which
is a loss of commitment.
And these are some of
the headings that it has.
And this is real.
The interesting thing is
that managers typically
spend a portion of their time--
guess what?
Mopping up residue, going
around with a mop and a bucket
tidying up the result or
the residue of things that
could have, should have
been handled more skillfully
earlier on in the piece.
People get paid to
come to work to mop up,
highly paid in many cases.
So does this resonate
with you by the way?
Or does this never
ever happen here?
Are you residue immune?
Or are you human?
So if that's true, here's
my question to you.
And it will be different
from person to person.
The question I have is,
how many hours a week
would you say, on average,
the average supervisor or team
leader or leader or
manager in Google
would spend tidying up residue?
Have a reflection.
So there's four categories here.
And I'm just going to
ask you to volunteer.
How many of us would
suggest or say no to five.
be in that camp.
OK, three to four people.
Oh, I've just given it away.
We're short on time so I
just kind of shortcut it in.
But at least we know
the three or four
people in the room we
believe it's less than six.
What would you say
your average is?
Would you be putting
it in this category?
Would that be the
general consensus here,
somewhere in here?
Yeah?
The international average
is about 12 hours a week.
Now, if we talk about residue
and what causes residue,
let me ask you--
so this is a piece where I'm
interested in hearing from you.
Because it manifests
itself differently
in different organizations,
but not too differently.
What I'm interested in is, if
you had to come up with reasons
why conversations go wrong-- so
if you want to go into the root
cause and do your
root cause analysis,
what are the things
that cause conversations
to go wrong typically in your
experience in Google here?
Give me an example.
Anybody?
I'm just going to take
anything from the floor.
AUDIENCE: Not knowing
what you want.
IAN MCCLEAN: OK,
so not knowing what
you want for the conversation.
So not having a clarity.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Back and forth,
doing things too quickly
and then having to come
back again and again.
IAN MCCLEAN: So doing
things too quickly
and then having to rework
and do it again and again.
We had over here.
AUDIENCE: Not listening.
IAN MCCLEAN: Not listening.
So people not listening.
I was listening by the way.
I was just paying
attention over here.
But I get what you mean.
AUDIENCE: Some hidden agenda
from different parties.
IAN MCCLEAN: OK, hidden
agendas from different parties.
AUDIENCE: Not knowing the
"why" you're doing it.
IAN MCCLEAN: OK, so not
only not knowing the "what"
but also the "why."
AUDIENCE: The wrong [INAUDIBLE].
IAN MCCLEAN: The wrong
people in the room.
Go on.
So Google is you.
AUDIENCE: Lack of context.
IAN MCCLEAN: Lack of context.
OK, so context is
either not [? not ?]
or different for
different people.
Anything else?
Was there a funny one here?
Because we'd love to hear it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
IAN MCCLEAN: What we typically
do when we work with groups
is we take this information,
and we put it together.
We take a sheet of flip-chart
paper, we take a red marker,
and we write up everything
that the group has got
to go through, and we put it.
And we call it the red list.
I'm going to come back
to that in a second.
So we'll take all of this.
We put it in a red list.
So I want you to imagine big
sheet of flip chart paper
here with all the red
stuff that includes
what you said plus much more
that's already in the room.
Here's the interesting aspect
of the whole proposition
is we're very keen to go back
to very simple first principles.
And the very simple
first principle
about effectiveness, whether
we're lead or we're not--
by the way, there's one thing
that I forgot to mention.
In the title of the talk,
it says effective leaders.
When I talk about a
leader in this context,
you don't need to be
anointed or appointed
with the title of leader
for this to apply.
And actually, even with
leaders that we've worked with,
when they come back
and they tell us
how this has worked
for them, [INAUDIBLE]
they come back and
tell us the human story
of how it helps them with
their 14-year-old daughter,
with their relationship at
home, with their whatever else.
So even if you're
not a leader in here
formerly anointed, as long
as you are a human being
and you've got a personal life--
and I won't even ask
you to put your hands up
if you haven't got one of those.
But as long as you have, then
this applies just as well.
And this is the reality of it
because it's a human reality.
We have a situation
where, to get
stuff done, unless
it's self-directed
and we're doing our own
thing on our own time,
a lot of what we need to get
done is through other people.
And you've got person
A, which is my side,
and you've got
person B, which is
the person on the other
side of the bridge.
And you've got a gap.
And as those in transport for
London continue to insist,
we need to mind the gap.
And that actually
is the challenge.
It is this fundamental
human challenge.
Because if we were
easy as this, we
wouldn't even have a business.
When given a problem
or a challenge to solve
and we've got to sit
down and work it out--
and there could be
A, B, C, D, E, and F
perhaps if it's a project
or if it's a team meeting
or whatever it happens to be.
Very often, what
happens is, instead
of moving in the
right direction,
the problem of a
challenge creates
a tension, which is A versus
B. Because I've got a view.
I've got a history.
I've got a prospective.
Caroline might have something
completely different
on the other side.
And we start to try and
engage to solve the problem.
And it creates a tension.
And part of the reason
it creates a tension
is because of the red list.
And the red list is real.
And it's also human.
And the thing
that's fascinated us
is that there's a policy and
a procedure for practically
everything.
If it's in the EU,
there's a policy
and a procedure for the
shape and size of bananas.
There are some organizations
we've encountered
where there's a policy on soda.
You can't bring soda
into the building
because it will ruin
their vending sales.
There's another
company that we work
with that has a policy
on furniture removal.
Because they're so
heavily unionized that,
if you want to move a
desk from here to here,
you've got to go and call
the furniture removal people.
So we have policies
for all of this trivia.
Yet we actually don't
have an operating system
for how to interact
with one another
to get a best result
or a best outcome.
It doesn't actually exist--
until now.
So the proposition is we know
that this red list is real.
We still have to solve the
problem of the challenge.
How do we navigate
our way skillfully
through what is
present very often
and produce an outcome that
isn't a residue outcome but one
which actually leaves us
with clarity and commitment
around the outcome?
So we know exactly what it
is we're supposed to do,
we know what the
context is, we know
the "why," we know that
"what," we know "how,"
we're committed to it, we have
the same idea of it, and we go
and we deliver it.
And we're committed to doing so.
That's the proposition.
And the final
thing before we get
into the brain science, which
I'm about to share with you,
is there's a cost to this.
And organizations are
really waking up to it.
Let me give you a really
crude residue calculator.
We'll start off
with the 12 hours.
So we take the 12 hours.
This is a real live example
of an investment bank
that we've worked with globally.
So 12 hours times 48 weeks
times average hourly salary
globally times the number of
people employed by the business
globally, and you get a
result. I did this presentation
most recently to 300
CFOs who are not normally
renowned for their interest
in conversations or anything
people-oriented usually.
And we were flooded
with inquiries
on the back of this one
slide that we've just given.
Because they did their own
maths with their own numbers.
And they came up with a
very, very large number.
Now, those of us who
aren't already gone
on holiday for the weekend will
appreciate that this number is
only half of the real number.
Because for every
one hour that I'm
spending tidying
up residue, it's
an hour that I'm not spending
doing what is actually going
to add value to the business.
So it's a six-point game.
If you get tired of the
football analogy at any point,
I can just switch metaphors.
Let me share with you the model.
The model is deceptively, but--
it's deceptively simple.
It's based on a journey.
So this is the GreenLine model.
And any journey that we have,
people identify with this.
So they relate to it very well.
Because we're all on a journey.
And whether it's a
macro-level life journey,
whether it's a career
journey that we're on,
whether it's a relationship
journey that we're involved in,
we're all simultaneously
on multiple journeys.
And whilst the journeys
are all different,
the elements of the
journey are all the same.
So one of the things you
need to have on a journey
is you need to have a
destination, which we simply
call the "there."
It's somewhere where we
haven't arrived at it yet.
We haven't got there yet.
It's over there.
And it's not where
we currently are.
So that's one fixed point
that we have in any journey.
The second fixed
point in any journey
is where we currently are.
You can take a snapshot in
time of any moment, which
is a "here."
If the language,
by the way, gets
too technical at any
point, please let me know.
AUDIENCE: Where?
IAN MCCLEAN: That's
in the middle.
So how do you connect
here to there?
What's the fastest way?
Straight line.
We actually draw it
as a dotted line.
Because life
teaches us that life
never really works
in a straight line.
And interestingly, we
have friends and clients
in the aircraft business
or airline business.
And they would tell us that,
if you take airplanes, which
most of us do a lot of the time,
then the airplane's trajectory,
it's in the aircraft's
interest to stay
as close to that
straight line as possible
for obvious reasons.
The first is it's the
most cost effective.
Secondly, related to that,
as you've identified,
is the fastest.
Thirdly, beyond that, it
consumes the least amount
of energy--
in this case, fuel,
which is tied into cost.
And finally, people can get
there faster and cheaper.
So they're happier.
So these could be the KPIs for
any business, any industry.
Interestingly, the
aircraft flight path
doesn't stay exactly
on the straight line.
They tell us that actually
it looks more like this.
It kind of wiggles and
wriggles from here to there.
And it actually only
intersects with a straight line
or the optimal line 8%
of the time on average.
8% of the time it's
connecting to the line.
92% of the time,
what's it trying to do?
Get back on the line.
It's a bit like Irish whether.
It's either raining,
or it's about to rain.
There's only two variables.
And you're either on the line or
trying to get back on the line.
And this is simple and easy
enough in aircraft territory.
Because what they simply do
is they put in the onboard
coordinates.
They onboard it of
the destination.
And then the GPS kicks in
and makes the autocorrections
all the way through.
That's how the flight works.
GreenLine just
follows that metaphor
but in the people sense.
So in order for a
GreenLine to work,
there are four key skills
that we need to have.
The first, which is obvious,
but not common practice,
is we need to create
an agreed "there."
We need to understand
what the purpose is.
We don't need to understand
what the destination is.
We need to understand
why we're doing it
and what we expect
as an outcome.
So that's the agreed "there."
Step 1.
The second thing
we need to do is
we need to be able to recognize
when things are going off
the straight line.
Because sometimes, if
we're working together,
somebody will always recognize
first that we're going off.
But it's the recognition of it.
Sometimes, it doesn't
happen, the recognition.
And things are way off
before we realize it.
So that's the second competency.
The third thing that people need
to do is they need to have--
and this becomes
the moment of truth.
Do I have the
courage to call it?
And this is very interesting
from a cultural perspective.
Because in some
cultures, the culture,
the habit of
behavior, the received
wisdom of how things
get done around here
is you never speak out.
And in some cases,
people break down
and they go the
opposite extreme where
people are speaking
out all the time
but then nobody's listening.
So there's an
element where do I--
because there may
be a tension that's
created by speaking out
or talking to somebody
or bringing it up.
That's a cultural issue.
And finally, the final element
of, is part of the reason
that people often
don't speak out
or they don't step in to
tap somebody on the shoulder
and say, I think we
need to address this
or we need to look at
doing it a different way,
is because they're
not sure that they're
going to leave the conversation
or the relationship
or the project in a better
condition or even as
good a condition as when they
found it before they tapped in?
So very often, very humanly,
they'll decide to avoid.
So this, essentially, is the
proposition of the metaphor.
In 25 years of working across
organizations globally,
what we find, sadly, is not
very much of this in reality.
What we find far more is this.
There's far more red line
than there is green line.
And you'll see the differences
in many, many different ways.
And we're to dig into
this now in a second.
And the green line outscores the
red in all four key areas, KPIs
that we identified earlier on.
And there are many
reasons why not.
So the proposition
for GreenLine,
which I'm going
to share with you,
there are seven green cards.
And the green cards
are the mechanism
by which we keep us close to
the center line as possible
and on the green line,
navigating from here to there--
seven cards.
And you've got a handout there.
But we're going to come back
to that now in a second.
The red cards are
the things that
are most likely in interactions
to cause the conversation
to go onto the red
line and, therefore,
in the wrong direction.
Before we get into
the cards, I mentioned
that my partner in
founding GreenLine
is in the neuroscience game.
And there's a really
robust set of neuroscience
that underpins the cards.
So I'm going to give you the
15-minute version of something,
which would probably take
15 hours if we had 15 hours.
But I'm going to give you the
short, simple version of it
because it's the weekend.
So the brain.
How many of us have an
interest in or an awareness
of the function of the brain
from a neuroscience point
of view?
How many of us have?
Not unusual and not surprising.
So that's really good.
So you can probably teach me a
thing or two even in addition
to what I'm about to teach.
So for those of us who
have or haven't, what
I'm going to ask you
to do is, would you
put your hand out like
this and splay out
your fingers and thumb?
OK, would you put your thumb
in, wrap around your fingers,
bring the fist toward your head,
turn around and turn your fist
and say, hi, brain.
AUDIENCE: Hi, brain.
IAN MCCLEAN: This is actually
a pretty good working model
of your brain, in
a couple of ways.
Firstly, it's about this size.
It's just a little bigger.
It's about this weight.
It's just a little heavier.
And there are two
component parts to it
that are two functioning
parts at minimum that
work in parallel with one
another simultaneously.
The first is the thumb,
which is one function.
And this is the limbic or the
older part of the brain, which
is called the feeling brain.
The fingers that
wrap around the front
is a more recent development.
And that's the neocortex.
And the two, they work
well independently.
But actually, together, they
can do an awful lot more just
like your fist.
But they actually
compete with one another.
And their function--
sometimes, they get mixed up.
So let me describe
briefly what each does
and where the risk is in the
context of our conversation
today on cards.
So let's talk, first of
all, about the green brain.
And the green brain
is a cognitive system.
A cognitive system is
something where our logic,
our ability for complex
thought, our problem-solving
capability--
so most of the time, from one
end of the day to the next,
this is on.
We are solving problems,
everything from programming
all the way through
to, what am I
going to wear in the
morning or tonight,
or what am I going
to have for lunch?
This is constantly on.
So when I say, 7 times 7--
49.
OK.
That is a good demonstration.
You've passed your [? MOT, ?]
your problem-solving brain
is working even at this time.
So you have to engage
your problem-solving brain
to solve a very simple
problem like that.
So that's the first thing.
The second aspect of the green
brain is it creates context.
What do I mean by that?
There are seven
birds on a fence.
You shoot one.
How many are left?
OK.
So the interesting thing is,
when you ask that question,
it ranges from none
to dead or alive.
So there are many, many
answers to the same question.
And it all depends on one thing.
Even the question,
dead or alive,
begs the question-- context.
What is the context?
So you change your context,
you change the problem you see.
Change the problem you see, you
change the problem you solve.
And we are infinite
context makers.
The human brain, each
of us individually,
is creating context every
minute of every day.
One of the challenges
is we often
think that, when we sit down to
have a discussion, that we're
operating from the same context.
When you disagree or you
can't agree or there's tension
or there's an A versus B in the
room, it is never about logic.
We make the mistake of
thinking that it's about logic,
and my logic is better
than your logic.
Disagreement is
never about logic.
It is always about context.
But by then, it's
often gone too far.
Let me demonstrate context.
I've got two marbles here.
Yellow marble is a dog.
Blue marble is a car.
Dog, car.
Put the two together.
It is impossible
practically not to have
a mental image in your
head with a dog in a car.
How many of us have got a
mental image with a dog in a car
as I was describing it?
How's your dog in a car?
Describe where they are.
AUDIENCE: It's sitting
down on the back seat
and watching out
from the window.
IAN MCCLEAN: OK, so the dog's
in the backseat of the car
watching out from the window.
OK.
Anybody else with
something different?
AUDIENCE: I imagined the
dog getting hit by a car.
IAN MCCLEAN: OK, so
we've got a dog lover
and a dog hater over here.
Yeah?
What have we got?
AUDIENCE: I have the car
that has a dog exterior
from "Dumb and Dumber."
IAN MCCLEAN: Yeah.
I know exactly what you mean.
Now, I've got that
picture in my head.
It probably won't leave.
AUDIENCE: I'm
thinking [INAUDIBLE]
so like the front
side [INAUDIBLE]
and then the back is a car.
IAN MCCLEAN: No.
So this beautifully
illustrates the fact
that all you need to do is
introduce two pieces of data,
and you can't help but create
an image in your own mind.
And it's different
from person to person.
So that's what I mean
by creating context.
So that's the second thing
that the logical brain does.
Interestingly enough,
we have great capacity
in this brain of ours.
And depending on which
piece of research you read--
since the 1950s, it vacillates.
We have the capacity
in the cognitive brain
to hold between not just
two pieces of information
like a dog in a car but
as many as between five
and seven pieces of information
we can hold simultaneously.
Now, here's the question I have.
If you can take six, let's
say-- we'll take the average--
data packs and you can hold them
simultaneously and you can spin
and move these and manipulate
them into any order or sequence
which will create a different
picture in your mind
or your ability-- this is the
wonderful power that we have,
computing power--
how many options
or possibilities
do we have if we've
got six variables?
Who knows the maths theory?
Six variables.
How many possibilities
or options?
AUDIENCE: 6 factorial?
IAN MCCLEAN: It is 6 factorial.
So it's 6 times 5 times 4
times 3 times 2 times 1.
So that's exactly
how many you have.
You've got a total
of 720 possibilities.
So we have the ability,
or the capability,
with the thinking mind
to engage with the world
and make of it with
all the data that we've
got that many impressions,
that many possibilities,
that many opportunities,
that many ways of looking
at the same thing.
It's quite remarkable.
That's what makes us brilliant.
But what makes us more
brilliant is the final thing
in the thinking route.
And this is what differentiates
us from the animal kingdom.
We have this ability
to imagine a future.
This is a little bit like
telling fish about water.
Because we do this without even
knowing that we're doing it.
But we are the only
mammal on the planet that
can meaningfully
think of a future that
doesn't exist currently,
imagine it to be the way it is
or isn't, work in the present,
and make decisions and spin
the marbles in creative ways
that enables us to achieve what
it is we imagined.
Squirrels don't do this.
They don't gather around
the squirrel family
and say, last year,
guys, we ran out of nuts.
We're going to have to kind of
delegate it out a bit better.
We're going to have to
create a spreadsheet.
And we're going to
have to figure out
how we're going to get
more nuts in so that next--
no.
What they do is they
actually just go out.
All squirrels instinctively
go out and find nuts
and bury them.
And they just hope that
they've found and buried
enough nuts that
there's going to be
enough nuts for the
squirrel population to find.
So it's a remarkable
gift that we have.
And actually, isn't
this future orientation
and this future capability
the very essence
of what leadership is?
The ability to imagine something
that doesn't exist and work
at the present and even subsume.
Because what
happens is the brain
organizes your marbles
for you, in order of--
so it sequences priority.
How do we sequence it?
So when the cognitive brain, or
the green brain is operating,
it sequences our brain and our
thinking from there to here.
So it enables us to make
decisions in the present
and even subsume some present
desires for a better future.
And for the greater good.
And we can make that
decision in the now.
It's what distinguishes
us from the animals.
So we are not the most--
we're not the strongest
mammal on the planet.
We're not the most naturally
armored or most armored
mammal on the planet.
We're not the fastest.
But we dominate the planet.
And it's because of
this ability to sequence
our marbles from there to here.
So that's on one side.
On the opposite side, we
have the feeling brain.
And the feeling brain has got a
completely different function.
The feeling brain does
not care about the future.
It only cares about now.
It's the older
part of the brain.
It's the limbic system.
And it's like a 24/7,
always on, surveillance
system that is designed
for one purpose only--
to keep you safe.
That's all it's got to do.
So you're a zebra.
You're grazing in the savanna.
A lion jumps out.
The last thing you
want to do is begin
to engage your thinking
brain and think,
I wonder, is it a hungry
lion or is it lunchtime?
I wonder maybe we could
make friends with the lions.
And if we befriended the
lions, we could probably--
no.
By then, you're already lunch.
So the red brain
only wants you acting
and wants you acting
as quickly as possible.
In fact, how quickly--
the red brain
reacts or activates
100 times faster than the time
it takes to think a thought.
Now, we can't even
imagine how fast that is.
But let me give you a
demonstration of it.
I recently had shoulder
surgery on this shoulder.
And when I came
out from hospital,
I had about 40 degrees of
movement in any direction.
So I could probably
do this and this.
And I was at home
rehabilitating.
And on my second day at home,
I was walking up the stairs.
And guess what?
I tripped on the way up.
So I'm in this situation,
and I'm going forward.
Before I had any chance to do
anything, guess what happened?
Now, I don't know if you've ever
had shoulder surgery and two
days later-- and you had
40 degrees of movement.
But you can probably imagine
what the pain was like.
But it didn't matter.
Because whatever pain
I was experiencing
in the future was
nothing compared
to what I would've
done if I had crashed
my head against the
stairs on the way up.
So what had happened was the red
brain had simply taken control.
So if you imagine,
it's like the cockpit
to go back to the aircraft.
You've got a pilot
and a copilot.
The green brain is like--
one of them has
got the controls.
Most of the time, the green
brain has got the control.
But occasionally, when
the need is there,
the red brain takes over.
It just moves in like a flash,
takes over the controls,
and makes decisions on your
behalf to keep you safe.
Why do you think it's 100
times faster than the time
it takes to think a thought?
Survival.
It's the older brain.
It's the preservation
of the species.
So the interesting
aspect about this
is that it also has an impact.
So your marbles have
sequence from there to here
and normally.
But guess what happens when
it takes over the controls?
Have you ever been
in a situation
where you were in a
meeting, somebody puts you
on the spot, like asked
you what 7 times 7
is in front of your peers
and that sort of thing,
and you're not expecting
it, and all of a sudden you
mentally freeze?
And something that
you-- you just freeze.
You can't.
You give you your best answer.
You come up with the
best thing that you
can think of on the spot.
You go off.
20 minutes later, guess what?
You think of all the things
you should have done,
should have said, should have,
should have, should have,
should have.
And as Ken Blanchard
says, all of a sudden,
you should all over yourself.
But you only
afterwards realize it,
because something has happened.
And something has
happened in here.
So what is happening here
is that the red brain takes
the controls, and guess
what it does first?
It resequence is
your marbles for you.
And it does it very quickly.
Fast enough for you not to
hit your head on the stairs
on the way up.
So now, instead of a
there-to-here sequence,
there's a
here-to-there sequence.
And the red brain
or the red marble,
which is the here
and now, and survival
becomes the very first thing.
The interesting
thing about survival
is that 21st century threats
no longer are in the savanna.
The 21st century
threats that we have
in Google and in
our organizations
and in our families are
now represented in the team
meetings and are
represented in the project
and are represented at home,
around the family table,
or between ourselves and some
other sibling, or whomever it
happens to be.
And now, when it
kicks in, what we
do is, in order to
keep ourselves safe,
the red brain is
taking controls.
We have to, in that
moment, make a decision
as to, how do I stay
safe in this environment?
What have I got to do
to get out of this?
What have I got to
do not to lose face?
What have I got to do not to
take responsibility for this?
By the way, it gets better.
So we got our six marbles.
If this lasts or persists this
state for about 20 seconds
or more, what ends up
happening is a chemical,
cortisol, gets released
into the brain, which
literally burns working memory.
So it literally burns off
your capability to think
and the range of what
you're capable of.
And it narrows it down.
So I've now just
lost three marbles.
I've gone from six
marbles to three.
I've lost half of
my working memory--
three marbles.
It's a trick question.
It's not even a question.
But it's a trick statement.
Because I've gone from 6,
which is 720 possibilities,
3 marbles.
What are my possibilities now?
6.
It's 3 factorial.
I've literally gone
from 6 marbles,
720 possibilities, down to 6.
And the 6 now are so clear.
Have you ever been
in this situation
where you were sitting at your
desk and an email comes in
and you go, that's the
fourth time this week.
I've got to do
something about this.
And you start to type.
You start to compose that email.
And as you start to compose it,
you get stronger and stronger.
You get clearer and clearer.
You're a wordsmith.
You should be a poet laureate.
All of a sudden, I should
have done this weeks ago.
And the kind of
energy surge that
goes in through there--
and you get to the point
where you want to hit Send.
And what does it
feel like when you're
about to hit that Send button?
You just hit Send, and you feel
like you've just taken down
the woolly mammoth, until 20
minutes later when somebody
walks in with a
copy of the email
that you just CC'd to
everybody and says,
did you really send this, mate?
By which time, the other marbles
that had fallen on the floor
have come back in.
And you now have a
perspective that you
didn't have at that moment.
Any of us here, have got
kids or access to kids?
Because I know, Caroline,
you're going off
to play with your borrowed
kids for the weekend.
Well-- and seen them
lose their marbles?
Because if we've seen
them lose their marbles,
we have a situation
where, let's say,
we've got somebody
who's five years old.
They've lost their marbles.
They're all over the floor.
And we, as parents, have a
strategy for dealing with this.
Now, if you're a
five-year-old kid
and you've just
lost your marbles
and you're down to
six options, you've
only got three left,
what is my ability
as a five-year-old to have
reasonable conversation in this
moment?
Very little.
So what do we do
as good parents?
Well-intentioned,
we reason with them.
At what point do we realize that
reasoning isn't going to work?
Well, normally, at the
point where they literally
drop one more marble.
And then they race off to their
room and they slam the door.
Because they've only
got two choices.
That's all they got.
Because they feel
more threatened.
So they lose another marble.
And we're just kids
with longer legs.
We think we're adults.
We think we're sophisticated.
But inside of us, there's
that five-year-old kid.
And the red brain
is the red brain
is the red brain when
it comes to that.
Now, I say all that to say that,
in most civil organizations,
what tends to happen is people
don't lose three marbles.
It's pretty destructive.
People comport
themselves in ways--
but it is fairly regular that
people might lose one marble.
What's the impact of
losing one marble?
The impact of losing
one marble is--
first of all, when the red
brain's resequenced the marbles
from here to there, what's
the marble on the end that
is going to go first?
It's the green marble.
It's the future-oriented one.
So now, we've got
a situation where--
I'm in a situation where the
least important element is
the future outcome of what
we're about to do here.
The most important
element is what
I need to do to defend myself.
And when I say, lose one marble,
one very simple example of what
that would look like would
be, you know the phone rings
and you pick it up?
And it's that number.
It's just that caller ID
number that's on there.
That's enough for you just
to trigger and just lose
one model.
Now, you're going to
prepare yourself differently
for that call, for
that conversation,
for that interaction
than you would do.
Because you've just lost
the future-oriented marble.
Interestingly enough,
if you lose one marble,
you go from 720
options to how many?
You go to 120.
You've just lost 600 options.
And they're the ones that
are most future oriented.
As somebody who has had to
lead and develop a business,
it's very critical
that, if we're
going to hire the best
and the brightest--
and the lengths
that you go to here
in Google and many
other organizations
to find, hire, and recruit
the best and the brightest,
we do that and they perform
in their 720-marble state.
But what happens when
people are under pressure?
Because it's only then that
you really begin to see how
people perform and
work under pressure.
And we have lots of
evidence of high flyers,
high potentials, very
talented people, very
gifted people who
around the organization
are just walking around
pulling pins out of grenades
and leaving the
grenade in the room
and walking right out there and
causing devastation around them
without even knowing
that they're doing it.
Simple hint.
If you're down to 120, one way
to help yourself and understand
and self-diagnose-- and
this is very helpful for me.
How do you know
you've lost a marble?
As soon as you find yourself
mentally moving into what
we call binary thinking--
it's either you or me.
It's either them or us.
It's either yes or no.
It's either black or white.
It's either-- as soon as
you find yourself moving
into a state where it
becomes binary, rest assured,
you are now in a
chemically induced state.
It's not a great
time to be making
decisions, which is why good
negotiators at that level
will always take breaks,
and lots of them,
to walk out to cool off
for that 20-minute period
so that they have got the
perspective of the 720
possibilities and
the 720 options.
Leadership reputations get made
or broken in these moments.
Marriages get made or
broken in these moments.
So that's the short science.
Let's do the short
version of the cards.
So what we've done
is, Blair and I
is, we've endeavored to create a
system to codify this operating
system that will enable
us, first of all,
not to create situations
where we're triggering,
losing marbles, and we become
suboptimal in our ability
to make decisions, make choices.
And also how do we
stay on the green line?
How do we avoid going
onto the red line?
So we're going to start off.
And I'm going to spend most of
the time in the remaining time
that we have-- oh.
OK.
We're a little short on time.
How many of us have
to leave at 3 o'clock.
That's going to determine--
OK.
So the very most of us.
OK, in that case, I'm going to
show you a five-minute video.
And I'm going to ask you
to have a look at the video
through the lens of the
red cards if that's OK.
So these are the cards.
They're pretty self-explanatory.
And the five-minute video
that we're going to watch
is a conversation between
two people, A and B,
who got two different
views of the same thing.
And they've got to
resolve a situation where
Barry, who manages Lisa
in a technical function,
she wants to apply for a
role which will promote her.
But it involves managing
people for the first time.
He doesn't believe
she's ready for it.
She believes she's already
demonstrated a capability
and that she is ready for it.
And they're in to have
a discussion around it.
We're simply going to observe
it through the lens of Barry.
So if you watch the
cards played by Barry--
and maybe the impact
that it's having
on Lisa on the other side
in terms of marble retention
or marble loss.
And once that's done, then
we'll just wrap it all up.
OK, so this is
the purpose of it.
So I'm going to flip
through the introductions.
And we'll just get
straight onto the cards.
So cards at the ready.
I'm not saying that all
of the cards appear.
And some of them might
appear more than once.
Let's see what you can see.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Hello, Lisa.
- Hello, Barry.
- How are you?
- I'm well.
And you?
- Good.
So you applied for a promotion.
Where are you at
with the application?
- Oh, well I haven't
actually filled it in yet.
I wanted to come to you
first and get your advice.
- How ready do you think
that you are for this step?
- Oh, I'm definitely ready.
I mean, I think I've proven
myself in my current role.
And I think I'll make a
good manager, actually,
if I'm given the opportunity.
I am a key contributor.
You say so yourself.
- Yes, you are.
It goes without saying.
You're a great asset
to this organization.
But how do you think that you
would cope with the greater
responsibilities?
- Oh, well, I would--
- It's a big step when you
move into people management.
I remember when I
was promoted myself.
I found it a big challenge.
There's a lot to take on.
And you're managing people.
You're coaching.
You're giving feedback.
You're doing appraisals.
It's a lot, you know?
And it takes a while
to get it right.
And you have a lot of
experience and a lot
of management potential.
Are you sure you're ready?
- Well, I think so.
Yes.
I mean, I've seen
a lot of people
with a lot less
experience and expertise
get promoted in the past.
And they seem to
be doing just fine.
I think I'll make a
good manager actually.
I'm looking forward
to the challenge.
And I'm already the one people
come to when there are issues.
And I'm often the one who has
to point out issues before they
impact the business.
And I think, with a
greater scope of influence,
I could influence the system
instead of just helping people
work around the inadequacies.
- Well, do you not think that
there are a few things that you
need to work on first?
- Oh, well, yeah.
I'm sure there are.
Such as?
- Well, for example,
your communication style.
How do you think
you come across?
- I'm not really sure
what you mean, Barry.
I am a key contributor
on this team.
I'm the go-to person.
I mean, I'm always willing
to help and give advice.
And I try to help them out
the best way that I can.
- Our last team
meeting, Kathleen
wanted to make a suggestion
about a potential change
to the report.
Do you remember how
you spoke to her?
- No.
- Well, you were
very condescending,
and you made her feel and
look like a bit of a fool.
Are you aware of that?
- Oh, come on, Barry.
Her idea, it was
impossible, and you know it.
I mean, she clearly doesn't
know how the system works
or she wouldn't
have suggested it.
I said what needed to be said.
And she got the
message, didn't she?
I mean, what do
you want me to say?
Be quiet, say nothing, and
let the business suffer?
- No, no.
Not at all.
Look, I just think that you
are very direct with people.
And that is not a style that
suits people management.
Look, I just think
that, at this moment,
your leadership style suits
more to an autonomous role.
Would you not agree with that?
- No, I don't.
I want this promotion, Barry.
I think I deserve it.
But you obviously don't.
- No, no.
Don't get me wrong.
Look, Lisa, I think
you're a fantastic worker.
You're a top contributor.
I just-- I want to support
you in achieving your goal--
- Frankly, Barry, it
doesn't sound like it.
- I just don't think
that you're ready
for this, not at this moment.
- Lisa, you asked
me for my advice.
I'm giving it to you.
And I think that we can work on
developing your people skills.
But in the meantime,
maybe something
comes up that doesn't
involve people management.
- You know, I'm fed
up waiting, Barry.
I want this promotion.
And I think I'm more than
capable of managing people,
actually.
- Look, if you really want to
move into people management,
we can do a development plan.
I'll look into some courses
that may be available.
And we can start there.
How does that sound?
- Yeah, that's fine.
Thanks.
- OK.
Look, why don't
we meet in, what?
Say, two weeks?
In the meantime, I can look
into what courses are available.
And I'll email you the link.
You can have a look at those.
We can have a chat about then.
How's that sound?
- Yeah, that's great.
OK.
- Good.
- Thanks, Barry.
[END PLAYBACK]
IAN MCCLEAN: When facts
doesn't really mean facts.
Could you see the
red cards at play?
How many did you count?
Four?
Any advance on four?
AUDIENCE: Seven.
IAN MCCLEAN: Seven.
OK, somebody got the full set.
It's like bingo.
Any recidivists?
Any kind of repeat offenders?
Which ones?
AUDIENCE: Asking
leading questions.
IAN MCCLEAN: Yes, yes.
Very often, it's a master
class in leading questions.
That's for sure.
OK, so the interesting
thing about it--
we talked about
operating systems--
and this is where
I'm going to finish--
is that we all have a
basic operating system.
We use it.
But we judge ourselves
by the intention
that we have, not the impact
that it has on the other side.
We either have an effective
operating system, or we don't.
These seven red
cards are the ones
that are most likely
to actually create
the impact on the other side.
Because what's the
impact on the other side?
Not very good.
And in rating it, when you
look at that conversation,
if you had to give it a rating
in terms of its effectiveness,
how would you rate
it here looking
at it through your
own lens neutrally?
2 or 3?
2's-- 3's is this
what I'm hearing.
OK.
Barry, now, on the other hand,
goes to his management meeting.
And he sits down with Aiden.
And Aiden says, I know you had a
difficult conversation to have.
How is he rating it?
7 or an 8.
I gave her the feedback.
I gave her the example.
We got a plan.
We're meeting in two weeks.
I think I got away with it.
Right?
A 7 or an 8.
Meanwhile, Lisa, whilst
tidying out her desk--
Caroline inquires
and says, well, she's
putting her effects into a box.
How did it go?
And she's rating it a what?
A 1.
Well, it's definitely
lower than we're rating it.
So now, you've got three
versions of the truth, right?
And there's only one
that is legal tender.
And that's Lisa's.
But the sadder thing about
it is, is that not only
is the impact on Lisa a
sad part of this equation,
but it's the
implication that there
are Barrys walking
around the organization
pulling pins out of
grenades and thinking
they're doing a great
job because they
don't have an operating system.
And he's not a bad guy.
He's doing the best
with what he has
to get a result in a
difficult situation.
And this is as good as he's got.
So guys, apologies for
running 4 minutes and 28, 29,
30 seconds over.
Because I normally
castigate people
for running over on
my side of the fence.
So mea culpa for that.
Thank you very much
for the invitation.
Caroline, thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]